foreign
so do your worries
a canoe is only as strong as its paddler
[Music]
the loon's call reminds us to listen to
Nature's wisdom
[Music]
a tree's true beauty is revealed in its
roots
[Music]
in the land of ice patience is a warm
coat
[Music]
the Northern Lights dance for those who
look up
Maple Leaves may fall but they never
forget their roots
a bear's strength lies in knowing when
to rest
[Music]
the river never rushes yet it always
reaches the sea
[Music]
in the forest of Life the tallest trees
face the strongest winds
[Music]
the best syrup is tapped from the heart
of the maple
[Music]
a wolf travels far but a pack of wolves
travels farther
Winter's silence teaches the most
profound lessons
a totem Pole's stories are told in every
carving
[Music]
the Snowshoe hair teaches us to adapt to
change
a strong heart is better than a heavy
purse
[Music]
the Aurora Borealis is a reminder of the
beauty in darkness
[Music]
the wolf in the Caribou share the same
land but not the same dinner table
[Music]
Eagles soar highest when they rise
together
foreign
Journey reminds us that no two paths are
alike
[Music]
the firewood warms you twice once when
you chop it and once when you burn it
the northern wind tests the strength of
your roots
[Music]
a beaver knows that persistence builds
Empires
[Music]
in the land of Ice and Fire resilience
is our greatest asset
[Music]
a lighthouse guides ships but a kind
word guides hearts
[Music]
the wolf and the Raven share secrets of
the wilderness
[Music]
a salmon swims against the current to
fulfill its destiny
[Music]
the first snowflake is the architect of
winter
[Music]
the quiet of the forest one finds the
wisdom of the ages
the snow May hide the paths but it
reveals the way
[Music]
strong heart and a warm fire can conquer
any storm
[Music]
like a maple tree one must stand tall to
be tapped for wisdom
[Music]
the river tells its story through the
rocks it carves
[Music]
the Moose knows that Solitude breeds
self-discovery
in the wilderness silence is the
greatest teacher
[Music]
the Eagle's vision sees beyond the
horizon
the wolf's howl Echoes the mysteries of
the night
the snow owl's wisdom is found in its
silence
a campfire is where stories come alive
and memories are forged
a tree's strength is in its ability to
bend with the Wind
[Music]
the wolf pack thrives when each member
plays their part
the forest floor holds the secrets of
generations past
[Music]
do not yell dinner until your knife is
in the loaf
[Music]
said than done
you can't catch skunks with mice
[Music]
the devil places a pillow for a drunken
man to fall on
[Music]
Once Bitten Twice Shy
trees Roots Run as deep as its history
the river teaches us that time flows but
memories linger
[Music]
a bear's strength is in its serenity
the tallest trees have the deepest roots
[Music]
a canoe Glides smoothly when Hearts
paddle in harmony
in the forest of Life find your own path
not someone else's
in the company of mountains one finds
Solitude and strength
The Whisper of the breeze carries
ancient voices
a wolf's gaze pierces through the
darkness of uncertainty
Winter's grip may be firm but the
promise of spring is unwavering
as cold as a polar bear's nose
a warm fire on a cold night is the
heart's Delight
patience is the warm coat that Shields
us from life's storms
you can't make a hockey team without
breaking a few legs
[Music]
if you don't have anything nice to say
say sorry
[Music]
you miss a hundred percent of the shots
you don't take
[Music]
next to trying and winning the best
thing is trying and failing
[Music]
in Canada winter isn't a season it's a
lifestyle
[Music]
apologies are like maple syrup you can
never have too much
[Music]
where the air hurts your face but the
people warm your heart
[Music]
conserving my energy for winter
the first snowfall is a blank canvas for
New Beginnings
[Music]
strong heart and a warm fire can conquer
any storm
don't keep all your tongs in one fire
don't get on the street car before it
stops
there is no place like home
there's no trailer hitch on a hearse
[Music]
some pursue happiness others create it
ideals hope Ambitions tumble into ruins
before the necessity of gaining Daily
Bread
grief changes shape but it never ends
[Music]
before
when you have expectations you are
setting yourself up for disappointment
[Music]
family is not an important thing it's
everything
[Music]
there are no passengers on spaceship
earth we are all crew
foreign
behind every great man is a woman
rolling her eyes
[Music]
the good physician treats the disease
the great physician treats the patient
who has the disease
what is most beautiful about the world
emerges from struggle
[Music]
it's the journey that teaches you about
your destination
[Music]
life is short every moment is precious
wow
the more knowledge you get the more
questions you ask the smarter you get
the more you realize that everything is
possible
[Music]
the time you feel lonely is the time you
most need to be by yourself
[Music]
faithful women in most cases have gray
hair
women who set a low value on themselves
make life hard for all women
don't compare yourself with other people
compare yourself with who you were
yesterday
through other people's faults wise men
correct their own
[Music]